tu vas me brancher cette menace
maintenant c'est important de se
mobiliser 10 buts tu bosses dans
l'humanitaire connais tu es tu va
concerner plus en afrique c'est qu'avec
mes potes on prend un billet d'avion un
sac de riz puis tac en afrique
bonsoir d'afrique jamais à la l'est
l'ouest le nord aussi pas mal un peu le
sud
mais là c'est le plan de ses salons maks
quoi avec sept chevaux tu nous lis
chopin
moi j'admire les mecs comme toi qui font
des trucs sympas comme devenir riche
tout ça
on a fait des sacrifices pour sauver sa
cuisine
nous avons besoin d'être savait comment
rachète une usine
nous assumons l'usiné vous savez pas ce
qu'on fait en fort très fort et vous
dites à personne que je suis nouveau
repreneur
vous êtes sûr que cette voiture vous
convient c'est parfait merci comme ça
pareil vous étiez ensemble à chaque fois
que le monde est petit [ __ ] une rolex
non limitation sa cause de gens comme ça
qu'ils achètent des contrefaçons qu'on a
plus d'emplois qu'on écoute au moins un
an
oh merde je te dépose si tu veux que je
fais ferme un peu ta gueule aussi tout
des fois il faut leur parler c'est bien
tard et puis je n'ai pas lu mariannautes
ont toujours un gros coup de l'été passe
quelque chose
là
c'est quoi ton secret on peut le charme
alice elle commence déjà à me regarder
différemment est ce que tu es libre ce
soir j'aimerais un coin bar sorte un
couteau
merci par gentil en fait c'est pour
combien de l'art tu me plais non mais tu
es venu le garder wallon tu as bien
compris
oui